[Applause]
turn super bowl 56 upside down
in one of the halftime show's many chart
toppers the rapper performed his 2003
hit in the club
when he was finished defying gravity 50
cent joined the star-studded ensemble
for the finale
snoop dogg dr dre mary j blige eminem
and kendrick lamar rounded out the
show's hip hop hall of famers and
following halftime busta rhymes told et
the performance already cemented an
important legacy what does it mean to
see this group of folks break through on
this stage i was fortunate enough to be
able to come and witness with one of the
rehearsals
emotional for me
for tears
yeah because but
proud and tears of joy though obviously
primarily what it means for our culture
is everything
everything but just on them on a
intergalactic level
beyond earth i think we proved tonight
that hip-hop
is part of the american dna jesse
collins one of the halftime show's
producers explained how this epic
production came together you know this
is one of the fastest first halfs in nfl
history
and so we had to make sure that there
was plenty of production value lights in
the stadium huge set and then just
monster hits monster artists how do you
make it with the moving pieces and all
the people popping up and down just an
incredible team i mean that thing came
on in i think less than eight minutes
tonight
the dps team the roc nation team the nfl
everybody just working hard knowing that
we had no choice you had to get that on
i only heard hits out there tonight and
i thought that was different because
usually artists want to do one or two
songs to advance a cause everybody did
hit absolutely i mean listen i think
that was established from day one
i think
whenever dre and jay sat down and said
these are the artists and these are the
records it was like we're gonna pick the
cream of the crop everyone is in tears
because
you know that
you know dre changed music
go back to nwa he made the world look at
the west coast and what they were saying
and then he has continued to change it
over and over again eminem 50 cent it
goes on and on kendrick snoop it's like
he keeps keeps changing music changing
music for the world i mean these are the
avengers of music all together in one
halftime show these are superstars
[Music]